can we talk about how every World Champ
right now is a giant gamer Max
verstappen who is extremely close to
winning his third straight F1 title once
said that he sometimes goes to bed
thinking about Sim racing more than his
actual job you know racing in F1 Nicola
jokic back-to-back MVP NBA champ and
triple double machine is also a huge
gamer if this shirt didn't make it clear
enough and his game of choice is League
of Legends then there's erling Holland
who once said this after breaking the
Premier League's goal scoring record so
I would go home now and play some video
games eat something and then sleep
that's what I will do and tomorrow we we
have to start thinking about leads
that's my life which video games are you
playing at the moment I cannot say it's
too embarrassing the game was Minecraft
UFC middleweight champion is yarisanya
was once in an Elden Ring trailer which
I guess makes sense since he's played
games his whole life so they play games
and touch grass
can any of us say the same